wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
das hat die letzte ja ich muss noch ein
paar getränke servieren die gäste hatte
ströer haben schon besteht dazu der
küche fast kein problem
was macht was meinst du die christen
ach so wir liefern die lebensmittel die
am wochenende übrig geblieben sind an
soziale institution die sie gebrauchen
kann
so kommst du jetzt ja ich komme gerade
von der agentur für arbeit ich würde ja
bald meine ausbildung beginnt bei jahre
ein spanischer abschluss ist anerkannt
worden
echt super freust du dich ja sehr
als ich klein war habe ich auch schon
gerne sachen repariert und bald verdiene
ich damit geld und wenn es irgendwann
einmal langweilig wird machst du einfach
eine umschulung umschulung ja du lernst
etwas neues teile und ich habe meine
umschulung gemacht als wir das
restaurant eröffnet haben
ich helfe dir
o
[Applaus]